معنى الانمي بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميس الياس العميد الياس
حنان نرحب بك العميد الياس قراءه طبعا
عسكريه واستراتيجيه للوضع فيل التي تعرضت
لهجوم بالمسيرات كما تعلمون وادى بالتالي
الى اغلاق خليجها
ازدهار
سيفاستوبول او شبه جزيره قرن تعتبر حيويه
للرئيس بوتين وهي هدف للرئيس لانسي اليوم
هناك التوقيت وهناك نوعيه الاهداف البارحه
نشرت مجله او مجله ان نقل المعركه الى
الارض الروسيه بلغ باستهداف 27 هدف ذات
قيمه استراتيجيه
شبه جزيره هي من ضمن حسب القانون الدولي
من ضمن الارض الاوكرانيه البارحه جونكاي
وهذه عقده سكك حديديه مهمه تم استهداف
صواريخ الكلبه هذه المنطقه هذه العقده
ازدهار تصل خرسون
بكرش وحتى ميزه بارود فاذا هي مهمه جدا
واستهداف سيستوبول وكانه هي عمليه
استباقيه لمنع القصف البحري بين الكاليبر
وبين القوات البحريه
وتتزامن مع زياره الرئيس بوتين منذ يومين
وزياره
وصدور قرار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وتتزامن البارحه الاعتداء على زياره
الرئيس تشييف اذا نحن امام مرحله جديده من
الديناميكيه على شبه جزيره القريب العبيد
الياس اي نوع من الثغرات تحديدا لدى
الجانب الروسي قد تكشف هذه التطورات
سفيان ليس هناك من امن مطلق مئه بالمئه
وليس هناك من حلول مئه بالم للمسيرات
المسيرات شيء جديد على مستوى الصراع ان
كان منذ الايام الحرب السوريه وحتى الحرب
الاوكرانيه اليوم لم يجد الافرقه بديلا
مهما او سلاحا لمنع هذه المسيرات الامر
مقلب جدا ومساحه المعركه كبيره جدا نتحدث
عن شبه جزيره خرم هي كبيره جدا وهي في
العمق الاستراتيجي والعمق اللوجي الروسيه
ولا يمكن حمايه كل هذه الاماكن ولكن سفيان
ما يظهر الامر ان هناك استعلاما تكتيكيا
واستخباراتيا مستمرا حول التحركات الروسيه
في شبه جزيره القرن نقطه اثرتها العميد
الياس تستدعي التساؤل حول
المسيرات التي تتصدر طبعا الاخبار
الميدانيه وتطورات في هذه الحرب ما هو
الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه المسيرات في
تغيير معادله هذه الحرب في تقديرك
ازدهار اولا المسيرات وكانها سلاح جو
للفريق الاضعف يعني الاوكران ليس لديه
سلاح جو مهم تستعمل هذا الدور تستعمل
وكانها سلاح مدفعيه تقصف الاهداف عن بعد
على سبيل المثال شاهد 136 تحمل تقريبا وزن
قذيفتين 155 وتقصف الهدف وهي دقيقه وكانك
عن بعد تضربينا شيء
انتحاري وعن بعد وليس له من اثمان ثمن
المسيره 20 الف دولار بينما الصاروخ الذي
سيسقطها هو يقلب فوق المليون او المليون
وكم من الدولارات فاذا انت هناك عمليه
توازن او لا تماثل تقارب لا تماثلي وكانه
لدى اوكرانيا لهم سلاح جوي يؤدي هذه
المهمه وحتى عن بعد
في سؤال الاخير بشان قذائف يورانيوم
المنظم التي ربما تنوي لندن تزويد كييف
بها الى اي مدى هذه الخطوه قد تكون خ طيره
اولا هذه الحديث عنها خلال لقاء الرئيس
التشي هذا امر مهم وكانه يقول هي رساله
للرئيس تشي انظر ماذا يفعل الغرب هي ليست
يعني هي لدى روسيه ايضا سفينتس اثنين وهي
صواريخ يعني
قذائف 125 مليمتر لديها تحمل
الايراني والمنظم هو يستعمل لخرق
التدريعات لانه اكثر من الرصاص ب 70 مره
له اثار على البيئه له اثار على من يكون
بقرب التفجيرات استعملته امريكا باجتياح
العراق اسرائيل باجتياح لبنان وحتى بصربيا
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا
امر فقط للتصعيد على غرار ما حصل باسقاط
المسيره فوق البحر الاسود شكرا جزيلا لك
من بيروت الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
العميد الياس حنا